E aí
[Música]
e se você pudesse criar um mundo como
seria quais as regras que você
estabeleceria quais os valores que
seriam praticados
essas perguntas podem parecer estranhas
mas e reais elas não são eu sou da
geração x nascida antes dos anos 80
quando o mundo era bem menos interligada
e carente de tecnologia globalizante um
mundo virtual foi naturalmente se
tornando a minha ferramenta de trabalho
e de uma forma Quase que imperceptível
acabou se tornando também a minha
diversão os momentos de lazer passou a
ser em grande parte do tempo o lugar que
o meu conversocial para novas interações
e até relacionamentos a era digital não
se trata mais do Futuro Ela já chegou e
já faz parte de tudo que engloba a sua
vida nesse exato momento mesmo que você
ainda não precisa ela te acompanhe ah
silenciosamente em cada parte do seu dia
sabe mais de você do que você mesmo
e parece até um pouco assustadora mas o
fato é que ela te conecta de uma forma
incrivelmente veloz a qualquer canto do
mundo otimiza seu tempo facilita seu
trabalho em poder empresas que uma
imensidão de dados e interações em rede
e te transporta para diversas músicas e
apesar de ainda me mantém muito
conectado as raízes da vida real eu não
posso negar que eu sempre considerei a
internet uma das invenções mais
brilhantes e sedutoras da humanidade a
minha vivência no mundo virtual e fez
conhecer novas pessoas no mundo que eu
nunca vi pessoalmente Participei de
números reuniões online fechei contratos
fiz cursos variados sem sair de casa e
até me aventurei a viver uma paixão
fulminante
Oi da eu me apaixonei perdidamente por
um fotógrafo que eu conheci na internet
Fantástico sensível amigo dos meus
amigos trabalhava com os maiores jornais
do mundo super bem relacionado
inteligente carinhoso humano e por
alguns meses a gente virou um madrugada
e papeando por vídeos até que eu
descobri que ele era perfeito para casar
se não fosse o pequeno detalhe de que
ele nunca existiu
e É uma longa história que daria um
ótimo filme mas a verdade é que esse
acontecimento me impactou e muito e me
fez questionar qual é o verdadeiro e
real sentido disso tudo a minha primeira
reação foi deletar foi fugir de tudo
isso na internet é muito comum encontrar
relatos de homens e mulheres que foram
enganados por perfis falsos muitas
histórias viram caso de polícia enquanto
outras apenas deixam marcas na vida de
quem se envolveu eu percebi que esse
novo mundo não é o melhor novos mundos
de certa forma a ampliar uma maneira
como as pessoas vivem
aprendem e se relacionam novos mundos
que não são necessariamente iguais ao
mundo real ou se quer assumir
compromissos com esse mundo não adianta
recusar se isolar e tentar não fazer
parte dessa realidade o nosso mais 7 tem
que estar preparado para essa evolução
porque a tecnologia EA forma de
comunicação que existe hoje estão
ligadas e vincular é absolutamente tudo
na sua vida hoje setenta por cento das
pessoas no mundo estão conectadas com a
pandemia o mundo virtual ele ganhou
outro sentido para mim é claro para
bilhões de pessoas também o
distanciamento social que na verdade é
um distanciamento físico fez com que o
convívio social no cyber-espaço se
tornasse algo ainda mais natural então
eu mergulhei em uma busca profunda
através de pesquisas e experiências
próprias para poder entender esse novo
mundo totalmente desconhecido e nessa
jornada eu descobri novas possibilidade
que contrapõe o maior de todos os
paradigmas o paradigma da realidade A
Minha Geração viveu uma das maiores
transformações dos últimos séculos a
mudança do mundo analógico para o mundo
digital não foi apenas uma evolução
tecnológica a forma como a gente pensa e
vive também mudou radicalmente a gente
saiu do mundo limitado por um a metade
quando consideramos as possibilidades do
mundo digital e a básica essa mudança tá
no que os pesquisadores chamam de desde
materialização
exatamente vimos o mundo se
desmaterializar diante de nós a desde
materialização do dinheiro da arte da
comunicação da música mais recente dos
bancos do cinema dá uma sensação de que
o mundo ele tá desaparecendo
diversos mundos são criados em cima do
nosso mundo atual através da tecnologia
as barreiras físicas são ultrapassados e
dão acesso a lugares
conhecimentos e experiências em outras
escalas de dimensões de forma ilimitada
e diante desse novo cenário de novas
possibilidades as coisas não estão
perdendo seu sentido pelo contrário Elas
estão ganhando novos significados e
ampliando a nossa forma de viver o
sentido das coisas não está limitada em
seu estado físico o João e a internet
sofreu a desmaterialização a gente não
precisa dele impresso hoje você pode ler
o jornal no computador no celular Aliás
você pode ler jornais do mundo inteiro
sem levantar do sofá O jornal foi
reduzido a sua essência ao seu propósito
que é levaram Notícias isso tá no nosso
dia a dia não é um livro mas a história
não é a carta mas a mensagem não é o
disco mas a música não é o dinheiro mas
o valor e quando falamos de
relacionamentos de convívio social
também não é diferente o estado eles de
fato são as novas frases de convívio
quando se fala em relacionamento segundo
um estudo realizado pela Universidade de
Stanford a maior parte dos casais hoje
se conhece online site de encontros
amorosos já demonstram ser hoje a forma
mais comum dos casais se formarão em
afinal de contas a gente conhece algumas
dezenas de pessoas na nossa vida né na
internet é possível conhecer e na
academia a gente vive o ápice dessas
experiências de novos espaços o fato da
gente não está no nosso trabalho nas
ruas no escritório né no teatro não
significa que a gente não tava junto
pelo contrário atingirmos recordes de
criação de comunidades e usuários e
desenvolvimento de novas plataformas
para nos conectarmos o real não é o
presencial somente o isolamento físico
ele abriu as portas da aproximação
virtual e todos nós certamente vivemos
tudo isso de uma forma muito mais
intensa do que a gente eu vou dar aqui
dois exemplos sobre isso O primeiro é o
caso da Jonathan Marques e da sua esposa
eles são proprietários de uma loja de
móveis e decoração para casa a loja
deles sangue bamgalô não só permaneceu
aberta todos os dias da pandemia no ano
passado como também dobrou as suas
lendas
e como a loja de John é uma loja virtual
encontrada no sé cuántas que é um mundo
online As pessoas vivem existências
paralelas por mês dos seus avatares
desde 2003 basta tá dentro do ambiente
que o usuário pode fazer qualquer coisa
até coisa festas boates fazer compras
com seu próprio dinheiro até ter uma
vida sexual ativa com outros personagens
virtuais enquanto a economia do mundo
real afundado 2020 o Second Life brava
com o aumento das fendas por parte de um
Boom econômico ou seja John tem uma loja
dentro de um mundo virtual em que
pessoas reais dentro de uma realidade
virtual buscam novas experiências e vale
dizer que junta contratando pessoas para
trabalhar na sua loja segundo o próprio
se ou da língua leve é uma espécie de
banco central simulador o PIB Geral do
jogo subiu 40 porcento nesse período mas
é só continha do sbac E você também pode
fazer dinheiro vendendo dente como
roupas Carlos Imóveis que tu acha
recentemente o terreno virtual foi
vendido por quase 1 bilhão de Dólares É
isso mesmo um terreno virtual no que
chamamos de meta verso que é uma espécie
de realidade paralela ambiente virtual
em que os usuários acessam por meio da
internet interagem ali com se adaptar
não é real né mas tem a intenção de
passar uma sensação de realidade e
possui toda uma estrutura no mundo real
para isso acontecer a compradora do
terreno virtual mais caro da história é
uma empresa com sede em Nova York que
investe em imóveis digitais alocados em
um dos digitais jogos como fortnite
plataformas the second life já deixaram
de ser apenas jogos eles são novos
mundos e novas qualidades que atrai a
atenção de milhares de pessoas que
passam a maior parte do seu telefone e
como sabemos tempo é dinheiro Outro
exemplo é o rapper americano Travis
Scott o que escolheu o jogo fortnite
para poder fazer a estreia mundial de
uma música inédita através de um show ao
vivo para os usuários do game o show
bateu o recorde de mais de 12 milhões de
espectadores simultâneos em 5 dias da
turnê a participação ultrapassou 27
milhões de usuários e quase 46 milhões
de visualizações a gente pode dizer
inclusive que os maiores eventos do
mundo hoje são possíveis somente em
espaços virtuais e haja festas encontros
casuais carnaval patrocinado por
empresas reais e até pessoas querendo
ter filhos e o negócio tá tão bem
organizado querendo a parte lúdica vai
dizer também que a frente que valorizam
a educação tem diversas iniciativas que
oferecem aulas e treinos para você
aprender um novo idioma numa escola com
o nativos Afinal o mundo inteiro
compartilha ali do mesmo ambiente esses
exemplos que eu dei aqui é só para
mostrar a nossa capacidade de explorar
os espaços
o virtual ou real com o objetivo de
ampliar as nossas experiências é muito
humano a gente acreditar e se sentir
seduzido por um mundo moderno e
futurista Ainda mais quando esse em
volta é uma grana sem fazer muito
esforço fica mais fácil ainda acreditar
e tudo começa a fazer nada mais sentido
quando descobrimos que a nossa
capacidade e plasticidade cerebral foi
Projetada para essas mudanças Para
vivermos novas experiências sejam elas
reais ou imagináveis esse o papo é
neuroplasticidade não tem como não
mencionar os estudos Pioneiros de
Michael merzenich aqui ele é um dos
principais neuro cientistas do mundo
professor da Universidade da Califórnia
em São Francisco ele fez uma das maiores
descobertas científicas do nosso tempo
que é constatar que o nosso cérebro é
uma máquina construída para mudar Ele
defende que é possível ao longo de toda
a nossa vida criar novos circuitos e
conexões neurais em respostas a
estímulos experiência o gerando mudanças
funcionais a plasticidade cerebral nos
permite remodelar e recriar novas e
múltiplas realidades então não se
assuste com tantas inovações nesse mundo
porque fomos fisiologicamente moldados
para viver novas experiências e meu
filho kauai ele tá com 10 anos ele é
todo conectado com a natureza não curte
muito videogame mas ele começou até
acesso ao celular depois que começou a
pandemia tão rapidamente ele ficou
íntimo de jogos como Minecraft Roblox e
numa velocidade assustadora ele
construiu o mundo virtual dele criando a
sua própria casa toda elaborada para o
Jardim ainda marcava encontro com amigos
da escola dentro da casa virtual mas o
mais interessante é que eu percebi que
quanto mais eles exploravam e se
familiariza vá com os campos virtuais e
com os recursos interativos mais natural
se tornando a extensão dele com seu
próprio Avatar criando entre eles havia
um relacionamento de e esse energia daí
eu pensei crianças né são lúdicas
misturo fantasias com realidade
até o ver um outro estudo realizado pelo
phd David renton que mostra que o que
vivemos no mundo imaginado tem um efeito
semelhante ao que vivemos no mundo real
ou seja o seu cérebro realmente não
distingue o real do imaginário no
experimento simples por exemplo os
cientistas mostraram que se uma pessoa
se imagina comendo e imagina todas as
sensações de mastigar e engolir de uma
forma Clara o apetite dela diminui como
se ela tivesse realmente comido o
cérebro pensa que você tá comendo e
ativa os sinais de Tô satisfeita e
depois e o significa que a gente tem
mais capacidade de moldar os circuitos
cerebrais a fisiologia EA saúde do nosso
corpo do que a maioria das pessoas
imaginam no sentido muito real você é
e pensa somos capazes de aprender e
reaprender infinitas vezes coisas
diferentes inclusive com lógicas
diferentes a gente tem o poder de
reviver diferente realidade inclusive ao
mesmo tempo com a mesma intensidade que
a gente vive como se fosse no mundo real
Então essa é a terceira reflexão nossa
Constituição mental não tem só a
plasticidade para viver diferente
realidade como também foi feita para
mudar constantemente e mais Sua
percepção é igual a percepção real a
minha última reflexão sobre esses mundos
possíveis é para mim a mais incrível de
todas se até agora o caminho que
seguimos foi no mundo virtual sendo um
espelho do mundo real com o diferente
possibilidade agora um novo cenário se
apresenta com uma ideia inversa os
atributos do mundo virtual passam a ser
uma realidade no mundo real imagina o
mundo virtual fazendo parte do nosso
mundo real e e
coloca seus óculos Inteligente você
recebe imediatamente as notificações
avisando sobre sua reunião Ou sobre sua
lista de tarefas do seu dia-a-dia
previsão do tempo mensagens você sobe na
sua bike e de repente a rua movimentada
de carros e caminhões se transforma num
caminho todo colorido cheio de belas
flores no seu passeio matinal e lá está
você na sua vida real vendo o mundo
virtual que você criou diante dos seus
olhos tudo junto e misturado Isso não é
um filme futurista e se chama a
realidade aumentada é a possibilidade de
mesclar o conteúdo digital com o mundo
físico permitido inclusive conexões
emocionais Profundas o impossível se
torna uma nova realidade e o único
limite da nossa imaginação o digital não
está mais confinado em uma única tela
ele permeia todos os espaços físicos e o
mundo real apesar de ser um plano futuro
e o Facebook vem trabalhando para
energia segundo da realidade virtual e
aumentada as pessoas vão poder passear
em pontos turísticos ao vivo em 3D
assistir filmes e vídeos como se
estivessem ali dentro dele imagina que
logo logo o seu avatar com a sua
aparência e roupas personalizadas vão
poder Navegar nos cenários virtuais todo
preparado pela promoção de eventos vai
conversar a interagir vai ter acesso a
vídeos ao vivo produtos 3D turbo virtual
entre outras coisas sem deixar de lado o
aspecto sensorial Você vai precisar
investir ali uma graninha equipamentos
mais complexos né como óculos de
realidade virtual roupas luvas e outros
acessórios e você ainda para poder
controlar e simular o toque sentir de
verdade os impactos de um golpe de tiros
até sentir cheiros e essa pode ser uma
experiência superior a de estar
fisicamente em um show um evento ao vivo
a formação de uma nova sociedade está aí
em diante dos nossos olhos e isso é
absolutamente incrível é realmente
inspirador que as pessoas se beneficiam
a tecnologia no seu dia a dia
especialmente no mundo cheio de desafios
como de hoje a gente sabe que máquinas
dispositivos e equipamentos são
essenciais para nossa sobrevivência para
o nosso crescimento profissional e
pessoal para aproximar pessoas queridas
que estão distantes criar conexões entre
pessoas que ainda nem se conhecem o
mundo virtual ele tá cada vez mais
próximo do mundo real e assim como no
mundo real também nos proporcionem
experiências complicadas e perigosas o
avanço tecnológico ele colocou o mundo
na Palma das nossas mãos e incrivelmente
a nossa capacidade humana tá criando o
mundo de Paralelos para serem vividas
por nós mesmos a escolha de como e quem
vai mergulhar nesse universo ainda
desconhecida é Nossa nós somos nós que
estamos por trás de tudo isso
e não tem porque temer seja qual forem
as realidade do real para o virtual ou
do virtual para o Real a nossa
capacidade de viver novas experiências
nos leva a entender que o ser humano
sempre será o grande protagonista de
qualquer muito possível
E aí